[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello and welcome to the mcu body count
where i'll be revealing just how deadly
the so-called heroes of the marvel
cinematic universe actually are i'll be
going over their appearances across the
franchise and tallying up just how many
people each hero put into the ground
right now the plan is for this series to
cover the original six avengers namely
iron man captain america thor the hulk
black widow and hawkeye if this does
well i may continue on and deal with
heroes introduced in phase 2 of the mcu
or maybe even look at some dc heroes but
let's not get ahead of ourselves because
we need to kick this whole project off
with the one and only tony stark aka
iron man iron man made his comic book
debut in tales of suspense number 39 in
1963.
the story was plotted by stan lee
scripted by his brother larry lieber and
drawn by don heck from a design by jack
kirby who also did the cover art for the
issue despite a long history in comics
iron man was frequently thought of as
something of a second string superhero
never reaching the heights of the top
tier marvel properties like spider-man
the x-men or even the incredible hulk
now that all changed when his first
live-action appearance hit screens
2008's iron man which kicked off the now
gargantuan marvel cinematic universe
tony is a brilliant but spoiled
industrialist having inherited his
father's business the biggest component
of said business being weapons
manufacturing but things take a turn
when he's brought face-to-face with the
devastation that his weapons bring to
the world and he's forced to build a
suit of armor to escape capture a suit
he then refines into something he can
use to try and make the world a better
place
he's portrayed perfectly by robert
downey jr who appeared to be able to
channel some of his own troubled past in
order to give tony the humanity that he
desperately needs in order to keep from
being an unlikable douche you've been
called the da vinci of our time what do
you say to that absolutely ridiculous i
don't paint and what do you say to your
other nickname the merchant of death
that's not bad but douche or not there's
no question that tony leaves a body
count behind the iron man armor in
addition to being a bludgeoning weapon
in its own right comes equipped with a
wide variety of weapons including
missiles tiny guided darts and of course
the repulsors though normally used for
flight they can be used to blast people
with considerable force let's take a
look at how tony puts these weapons to
use start running down the body count we
of course kick things off with where the
entire mcu started iron man 1. though
there starts being a body count pretty
early into the film tony himself doesn't
start racking up kills until he breaks
out of the cave where he's being held
captive by the terrorist organization
the ten rings and since i'm not doing
full recaps of these movies we're gonna
start there
but boy once he gets started he does
some serious damage we start off with
these two guys taken out when the door
is blown off now i suppose this is as
good a place as any to acknowledge i'm
going to be using my own judgment on
what does or doesn't look like a
fatality to me this isn't based off any
realistic injury assessment i didn't
consult with medical professionals this
really is just my own gut instincts as
well as my knowledge of the tropes of
action films in other words villains
especially minions and grunt types go
down permanently from injuries that the
heroes would just walk off if they took
but that also doesn't mean that every
single hit and slam counts as a kill
i am going by how lethal it looked to me
based on physical impact narrative and
film framing and also whether or not
there is any movement after they go down
if we get any further shots of them
which brings us back to the two taken
out by this door when it gets blasted
off now i could buy that they survived
except we get a follow-up shot soon
after and they are down and out for good
so far as i can tell i did decide to
credit these kills to tony even though
his buddy jensen
probably would have been involved in
rigging up the entire bomb setup and i'm
giving tony the kills because
because i decided to okay
you want to do it different you can do
your own count jeez
why are you so confrontational about
this calm down
anyways once the suit is fully powered
tony gets to work escaping the cave i'm
counting this guy punched across the
frame because if he could still do
anything at all he'd have kept shooting
after he landed under other
circumstances i might count that as a
knockout but as we are about to see tony
isn't going light on these guys
not at all we've got these two slammed
into the wall which i'm gonna count as
kills largely because of how crunchy the
impact sound effects are
now i went back and forth on whether or
not to count this guy who gets punched
in the head straight into the ground on
the one hand it's a direct hit to the
head and he goes down very hard on the
other hand tony doesn't actually have
metal fists in this first iteration of
the iron man armor it's actually heavy
duty work gloves as we see in an earlier
close-up but ultimately i am gonna count
it again due to the crunch sound effect
used for impact
as mark one iron man works his way down
the hall we have another three going
down with extremely crunchy hits
tony is pissed and he is not holding
back during this entire thing which is
the same reason i'm gonna count this guy
who gets locked in with tony we only
hear that he stops screaming to be let
out so we don't really know what tony
did to cut him off
but given the headspace tony appears to
be in i don't see him going non-lethal
on the guy so i'm going to count it next
up we get this guy flattened by a very
heavy door and this guy gets
clotheslined
[Music]
although the clothes lining is not as
crunchy and impact as some of the others
it is direct to the head with a metal
part of the arm so i'm gonna count it
based on what i said before about how
pissed tony is and how much lethal
intent he appears to have throughout
this next we've got this guy who goes in
for a head shot on our hero and it
ricochets right back at him it's not
exactly an intentional kill on tony's
part but i am gonna count it because the
suit was built in a way that allowed
this to happen plus
let's be honest even if it didn't happen
that way tony would have crunched him a
second later regardless next up we get
sort of a leader figure who goes down
from proximity to a rocket blast but he
shows up later in the film so we know
this one isn't fatal even though i might
have counted it as such otherwise it
does leave him with some pretty serious
scarring though once tony's out of the
cave it's time for the flame throwers we
get two terrorists fully engulfed in
flame i'm also gonna count this guy
who's on fire and stumbles backwards
into more fire
then we get this guy who's blown back
when tony ignites some of the munitions
and from there the baddies actually put
two and two together about what they
should be doing and they start
retreating even as they continue to try
and gun him down tony at this point also
shifts his own focus onto destroying the
weapons and putting much less emphasis
on taking out the terrorists but
when he takes off it is very explosive
and we get this gunner on the hill fully
engulfed in flames by the takeoff now
even though we only see that one guy for
sure taken out the blast is so big that
i'm gonna count all the baddies that are
in the preceding shots shooting at tony
because they did not have time to get
clear of all this by my count that adds
seven because we have two separate
close-ups of these two guys in cover and
then there's this group shot of five of
them who are out in the open
now i am presuming at this point that
any additional members of the ten rings
that we might have seen earlier have
already fled even though it's possible
they might have been caught up in the
blast too
the thing is there's no way for me to go
back and say count the folks who were
out in the open when tony first exit the
caves who i didn't already count as dead
i can't really include them because i
don't know where the physical proximity
is during the takeoff and i risk double
counting the ones that i've already
listed here so even though it's possible
he took out more than i'm giving him
credit for i am going to leave it here
tony makes it home and then things go
quiet for a while on the killing front
well that is until tony decides to go
and inject himself into a hostage
situation with his newly upgraded suit
we're going to start with this punch
that sends a guy flying back into a wall
given the air time and the dent that he
leaves in the concrete i'm gonna count
that as a kill
next up we've got repulsor blast which
is one of those things that it it's
pretty debatable and a bit of a
case-by-case basis on whether or not
these should be counted as lethal
it probably depends quite a bit on
proximity
now this guy goes back hard and leaves a
pothole in the wall behind him so i'm
saying that's fatal partially because of
how hard he would have had to have been
blasted to make that dent than the dent
itself out of the next two blasts that
tony lets off i'm only gonna count the
first one as a kill my logic here is
that this guy's even closer than the one
we saw get knocked into a wall so even
without concrete to slam into he's
getting a much harsher blast this last
guy is at the furthest distance and just
goes tumbling over some crates
comparatively gently so i'm gonna say
he's more likely unconscious or maybe he
uh did the smart thing and fled the
scene next up tony uses some
i guess i'm gonna call these needle
shots using an auto targeting system
tony takes out a cluster of baddies
before they can harm civilians now to my
eye there were only five of these guys
but tony's targeting system picks out
six and one of those appears to be
shadowed in the truck who i just
couldn't make out with the naked eye so
you know what i'll trust the system and
i'll count it and yes i am gonna count
these as kills despite not being
entirely sure exactly what it is that
tony's shooting at them because these
guys just flat out drop there is no
evidence that these are tranquilizer
darts it's not like they swoon as they
go down they're just out
next up tony has his encounter with a
tank blowing it up in one of the film's
iconic images so the question here is
how many got taken out in the tank
explosion well i did look into this a
standard modern tank crew consists of
four people commander gunner loader and
driver but that doesn't guarantee that
there were four people in that tank
technically one person can operate a
tank on their own just not very
efficiently since they'd have to be
constantly moving about inside the tank
two different positions in order to load
the gun aim the gun or drive the tank to
a different position so that means that
this blast could count for anywhere from
one to four for our purposes
ultimately i opted to split the
difference and call it two but i'm not
just going by averages for that i do
have a logic behind it given the
resources of the terrorists it seems
unlikely that it would have been
properly manned with a full crew plus we
never actually see the tank move however
the aiming and firing is done
efficiently enough that i think there's
two guys in there a loader and a gunner
but probably no driver and no commander
so that is two more for mr stark
shortly after that tony blows up some
jericho missiles presumably killing any
10 rings members in the immediate
proximity now by my count from what we
see that brings in another seven
now even though the movie isn't over
that's actually going to wrap things up
for the first iron man as far as a kill
count goes because we know the pilot in
the jet that tony wrecked made it out
okay the film made a point of making
that clear and i'm going to credit the
death of the big baddie obadiah stain to
pepper potts for being the one to throw
the switch and end him sure
it was tony's plan but she's the one who
executed it
no pun intended
okay
maybe maybe a little intended but that
brings us to iron man 2 in which tony
kills
nobody
seriously it is a big fat zero all the
destruction logically might have had
some collateral damage
but there's nothing in shot that ever
confirms or even indicates the
possibility of that plus all the baddies
that tony takes out are robots even the
main villain whiplash ends up blowing
himself up because he's a sore loser so
yeah
tony's got clean hands in this outing
next comes the big team up the avengers
and this is where i need to remind folks
who may not have watched my intro video
for this series i'm only counting kills
of what i'm comfortable considering to
be sentient and or sapient beings i'm
not counting anything that behaves as a
hive mind or an unthinking horde now the
chittari are probably the group i'm
going to get the most pushback over
lumping them into the horde category i
don't think i'll get too many objections
over considering the ultron bots or
whatever these things were that bulked
out thanos's army as hordes or mindless
beasts
and i'll grant that the chatari can
appear to operate with individual
thought but
the clincher on this for me was the fact
that when the mothership is blowing up
they all drop dead
that to me says that they function as a
group not as individuals space wi-fi
goes down and they drop and it's not
even like their life support systems
cacked it they're not struggling to
breathe or succumbing to earthly
infection
they just drop and to cement to this
standpoint i even did a little extra
research a bit of official lore that was
tied to the tv show agents of shield
describes a chitauri neural link and it
includes the following sentence the
chitauri are of a hive mind a singular
collective of alien cyborg like
creatures working as one to overwhelm
their enemies
okay so technically it said cyborg-like
not cyborg-like but that looks like a
typo and a piece of bonus content that
was probably given to an intern to type
up but my point is
these are not to be considered as
individual creatures so
they don't get counted
however
i do feel it's safe to assume that on
the mothership or possibly even the
mothership itself
was some kind of controlling
intelligence be it organic or cybernetic
and that was taken out by the nuke that
tony redirected so
you know what
you can have one for that tony as a
treat
that brings us to iron man 3 and yes
tony does start racking up the bodies
again after publicly challenging the
terrorist leader the mandarin tony's
home is attacked by helicopters tony is
forced to use an iron man suit that
isn't actually combat ready but in a
clever bit of improvising he uses his
repulsors to launch a grand piano at one
of the helicopters now much like with
the tank and the first iron man i gotta
make a call on how many people i think
went down with this thing we get an
earlier shot of a different helicopter
that shows the pilot and one other
person in the passenger seat so it's
tempting to say that there's two people
in each chopper however on closer
inspection during a zoom close-up of the
pilot who gets a piano to the face
i don't see anyone in the passenger seat
plus we get a quick side shot that
appears like nobody's in the back either
so i'm only gonna give credit for the
one kill old buckethead has to be
creative with the next chopper too his
weapon systems aren't fully powered but
there's still some armaments that he has
so he grabs a missile that he can't
actually launch throws it at the
helicopter and then blows it up with a
repulsor blast now as before i'm only
going to count this as one kill because
a later shot confirms the surviving
chopper is the one that we know had two
guys in it there is also a quick
interior shot of the helicopter that
gets blown up and it only shows the
pilot and well it's from an angle that
it can't be said as definitively that
there was nobody in the passenger seat
ultimately i have no evidence of a
second person ever being there so i'm
only gonna count it as the one the third
helicopter wrecks tony's home sending it
and tony into the pacific ocean and
leaving him for dead later in the movie
tony now suitless faces off against some
baddies powered by a regenerative
treatment called extremis this makes
them stronger and deadlier but extremist
also gives people a tendency to
let's say overheat
tony's able to take down the first of
these durable fighters by releasing gas
into a room and then placing metal dog
tags in a microwave to spark and ignite
the gas it's actually one of the fun
things about this entry in the franchise
how much it requires tony to get by
without his high-tech suit or at least
not all the functions he normally has on
it that said the suit or at least part
of it does come into play for taking
down the next extremist soldier with
tony delivering a full repulsor blast to
this guy's face now i was really ready
to count this guy whose name's sabin by
the way as a kill
but
i noticed later that he's the same guy
who takes over air force one a little
bit later in the movie so
i guess not
that said i do feel like it's safe to
say that he only survived due to
extremists and any normal human would
have had their ticket punched by that
blast which would reaffirm my belief
that the repulsors can be lethal by
themselves at a high enough charge or
close enough range later on in the movie
tony infiltrates a miami mansion where
he believes the mandarin is hiding and
there's some pretty iffy non-lethal
takedowns i went back and forth on
there's some straightforward stuff
that's clearly non-lethal like a
tranquilizer dart and a taser takedown
but then there's these two guys who have
small explosive devices go off in
extreme proximity to their heads
ultimately i did decide not to count
them going back to what i said in the
first iron man you may remember that on
questionable instances in that one i
leaned in favor of counting them as
kills because tony appeared to be going
about things with lethal intent so by
the same token but on the other side of
it given how non-lethal the earlier
means are the plan on tony's part seems
to be just to knock the guards out and
while that doesn't preclude an
unintended kill i'm gonna say tony was
successfully non-lethal here and i did
double check this guy in the fountain
his head's not under water when tony
leaves him
later on while escaping from capture i
am going to say that tony definitely
kills this guy with a repulsor blast now
it's at a distance that could go either
way in a vacuum but tony told the guy
straight up he'd kill him just a few
minutes before
i'm gonna kill you first
i'm gonna say he succeeded in that he
knocks the other guard around but it
didn't look fatal to me a little bit
later tony does shoot one of the guards
so i'm gonna count that he then slams
another into the wall and flips him over
though again that second guy didn't look
like he took hits hard enough to die
from there's one more guard but rather
than fight he gives this amazing line
honestly i hate working here they are so
weird and very smartly runs away next up
iron man goes against savin on air force
one and while the repulsor blast to the
face before didn't kill this guy
the chess blast definitely goes straight
through him and also the wall behind him
and that's actually going to wrap us up
for the final iron man movie because you
see the big climactic battle has
extremist soldiers fighting unmanned
armor what tony calls the house party
protocols
the call i had to make here was whether
or not to give tony credit for any kills
done by the unmanned armor since to be
fair he made them and ordered them into
the situation
ultimately i decided not to though
because he actually has his ai butler
jarvis controlling them jarvis target
extremist heat signatures disabled with
extreme prejudice
and jarvis is established in the next
avengers film to be borderline sentient
on his own
now if i ever do phase 2 heroes and
cover vision i'll have to decide whether
or not to count jarvis kills towards
visions total
but that's a problem for future me so
have fun with that
as for the big baddie one aldrich
killian like obadiah's staying before
him he is taken down by miss pepper
potts seriously tony she never stops
taking out your trash
i do anything and everything that mr
stark requires
including occasionally taking out the
trash now it's time for the next big
team up and let me say this up front
this opening action scene in the age of
ultron
it was a nightmare to try and get an
accurate count on between how fast it
all happens trying to figure out what
should or shouldn't be counted as fatal
and just flat out counting the number of
guys who get knocked down or around this
was a
huge pain in my ass
but here we go tony kicks off his count
by blowing up this turret and we see a
little bit later in the movie that these
are manned by two soldiers so i'm gonna
give him two kills for that next up
comes this tank and i agonized a bit
over who should get credit for this
because thor flips it in the air tony
blows up the underside
and then hulk throws it who knows where
i decided i wasn't going to give it to
hulk just for being the last one to
touch it so for me it was between thor
and tony
to my way of thinking thor's hit
would have killed them when the tank
landed but not from the initial impact
of the hammer however tony's explosion
to the underside probably did the job
before the thing ever had the chance to
hit the ground much less get thrown
around by the hulk
now in iron man 1 i did hemen ha a bit
over how many kills the tank explosion
should count as but that was for a
guerrilla terrorist group this is hydra
and hydra is properly trained and well
armed so for my money i'm saying that
the tank has a full crew so that's four
added to the count
from there he hurls this guy into a tree
at very high velocity and if skiing into
a tree was enough to take out sonny bono
i'm saying this is enough to count that
guy's dead
iron man then blows up what looks like a
gated checkpoint but i couldn't confirm
if anybody was close enough to be
counted as a kill so he gets nothing for
that [ __ ]
language next we see him strafe the
hydra base and when the shot starts
we've got two already on the ground that
he presumably already took out then
there's this cluster of guys on the
stairs now though there's six hydra
agents here i'm only gonna count three
kills three is how many shots tony fires
and though all six go tumbling i'm
making the assumption that the three who
were not directly hit are just being
knocked over by the ones who were tony
then comes in for a landing blasting two
over the rails and then a third soon
after we've already gone over how deadly
the repulsors can be on their own at
close enough range plus
if there is a railing that's probably
not an insignificant drop he just sent
them over tony does not seem to be
holding back during this initial attack
because next up we get this absolute
massacre so i'm not gonna count the
first airborne guy tony hits because
firstly the guy's armored secondly he
really only gets punched quite hard but
again the armor thing the next airborne
gent i am going to count because tony
blass him and then there's all these
guys on the ground and that's tricky
because of the cuts in the editing in
terms of getting a count i could easily
have either missed a few or double
counted but
to my eye there's 10 of these guys who
go down before tony obliterates the
truck next up is the question of how
many people does he get credit for the
truck explosion my initial instinct was
that the truck was transporting fighters
to the battle
but there's a brief flash from inside
where we actually see some of the
interior of the truck lit up and there's
no silhouettes of people illuminated
plus no signs of bodies when he comes
out the other end so based on that i'm
only going to count the driver so adding
up the earlier ones that's 12 taken out
in this stretch
next tony breaks into the hydra base and
in doing so he hits these two guys on
entry but they just look like they got
knocked down the stairs however there's
these six guys and tony breaks out the
needle shots and these guys all go down
including an unarmed guy who was
cowering behind a map
nice one tone
although hey look at that it's non-fatal
it's an odd point in the battle to
decide to stop using lethal force but
hey
baby steps i suppose oh and before
anyone asks no this does not mean i'm
gonna reconsider these needle shots as
deadly from when i talked about them in
the first iron man in that one the guys
went down and stayed down in this one
they're clutching their legs and the
like so it looks to me like these things
can still be lethal tony just didn't aim
for deadly spots on the body this time
around it's a good talk no it wasn't so
he actually gets nothing for this bit i
am however going to count this unarmed
scientist type because he doesn't get up
and we don't hear even a moan from him
after taking this hit plus afterwards
tony puts the suit into quote-unquote
century mode and it's not keeping an eye
on the guy on the ground it's looking
around for potential new threats
presumably because it knows that guy
is definitely not getting back up later
on there's the fight in the tanker with
claws goons but tony's focus is pretty
much exclusively on ultron so no kills
there we also have the fight between the
hulk buster and the hulk and during that
we get this moment where tony throws
hulk hard into an oncoming truck like
right at the driver's cabin and i'm i'm
sorry tony but i'm counting that as a
kill because there was no way the driver
survived that and the hulk only landed
there because you threw him i know you
went out of your way to avoid civilian
casualties as established later but
i think he killed somebody there
from here on out the rest of this film
is all ultron bots which act as a horde
and i do not count individual bots as
sentient so we're moving on in captain
america civil war since the majority of
combat is between the heroes there
aren't going to be any fatalities in
something like the airport fight there
are some kills in the opening action
scene where the avengers go up against
crossbones and his goons but tony isn't
involved in that so
that's another kill-free outing for the
iron dude tony's next major appearance
is in spider-man homecoming and while he
does do some stuff in the iron man suit
none of it is actually taking on the
villain or even the villain's minion so
it's another case of zero body counts
and now that brings us to
infinity war a film
kinda notorious for its body count but
once again
i'm counting the bulk of thanos forces
as a horde so the heroes don't actually
get that many kills that i would count
but you know what does count
thanos is lieutenants so that means tony
gets himself a kill by causing ebony maw
here to be sucked out into space it may
have been spider-man's idea but tony
executed it and i did mean the pun that
time
this is however tony's only kill in this
movie and that brings us finally
to end game
now as with infinity war the majority of
kills are on mindless horde beasts and
the chitari so huge chunks of the action
scenes don't feature any deaths that
count for the purposes of this show
however thanos himself and his
lieutenants they still count now prior
to tony doing his own snap call obsidian
was crushed by scott lang in giant form
and corvus glaive got taken down by
okoye proxima midnight is a little bit
tougher to track you see the actress for
the voice and the facial capture carrie
[ __ ] couldn't make the end game shoot
due to scheduling conflicts now proxima
midnight is still seen in some of the
long shots and group shots played by
stuntwoman monique ganderton so she's
definitely there but since [ __ ] couldn't
do the facial capture she gets no
close-ups and no spotlight so while it
is possible she died during the battle
like obsidian englave did
we don't see it happen so i'm going to
assume she's still alive when tony snaps
thanos forces away so that means tony
gets three for his sacrifice play one
for approximate midnight one for ebony
maw who we do in fact see get dusted and
of course thanos himself
so that
closes out the murderous rampage of one
anthony edward stark aka
iron man how many bodies did he leave in
his wake well let's run the numbers and
find out in his time as iron man tony
stark racked up a total body count of 82
with over half of that coming from his
very first film having significant
appearances in nine marvel films because
i'm not gonna count something like the
cameo in the incredible hulk that means
that on average tony killed
9.11 people per film
of the 82 i am crediting him with 77 of
them were humans of some form with two
having enhancements from extremists and
one being a poor innocent truck driver
tony only had five non-human kills
although one of those non-human kills
was the big batty daddy of them all
thanos
i almost want to count that as more than
one
but in the end he's just one guy like
everybody else no matter what he claims
to be
i am
inevitable
you know what else is inevitable the end
of this inaugural entry in the mcu body
count now next month i'll be taking a
look at how many bodies have been left
behind by the first avenger captain
america aka
steve rogers he had seven appearances to
tony stark's nine but given how many
times tony didn't notch any kills at all
he still might be able to give the old
metal had a run for his money tune in
next month to find out and that wraps us
up if you want to support this project
or anything else that i do patreon is
the best way to do that but i really
want to get your comments on this what
do you think of this project what do you
think about how deadly tony ended up
being was it more than you thought was
it less whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments and let's
talk about it all the like share and
subscribe stuff helps me out as well but
what i really want you to remember my
friends
is that you are beautiful you are valid
and you are loved
you're the council i'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
now my thanks to my highest supporting
patrons robin moore zubin lutfullah
barack the thing that goes doink in the
anime oliver b melinda walters and
delkey the oath the boy bernabby lacks
the poodle zach idolin tracy skravit
angry casper bookworm
adam rdl taylor shane ross ring borlay
brendan the rose and tt
you want to hear me possibly butcher
your name check out the rewards on the
patreon
and thanks to all you friends
[Music]
[Music]
so
um
[Music]